avec le coronavirus l'école se
réorganise en dehors des classes par le
passé la france a déjà dû mettre en
place l'enseignement à distance en 2009
des classes avaient dû fermer à cause de
la grippe a
avant même la rentrée scolaire
l'éducation nationale avait prévu une
solution d'école à la maison la
télévision six cents heures de
programmes de la maternelle à la
terminale sont prêts à être diffusés
sous chaque marguerite il y à une lettre
600 heures de cours de quoi occuper les
élèves pendant trois mois
c'est la durée maximum prévu finalement
pas de cours à la télé car il n'y a pas
eu de fermeture des écoles au niveau
national la solution pour les élèves
concernés s'étaient internet
exemple d'une école dans le val de marne
ceux des 36 élèves qui espéraient une
semaine supplémentaire de vacances se
tromper une équipe d'informaticiens du
rectorat a été dépêchée en urgence au
lycée pour permettre aux professeurs de
mettre en ligne leurs cours et leurs
consignes dès ce matin pour leur
professeur d'histoire l'agenda est
envoyée préparer le premier chapitre du
programme d'histoire de le fichier et de
les prévenir qu'ils auraient un contrôle
en rentrant sur ce même chapitre de
l'autre côté confinées chez elles
lisa reçoit le message contre de
connaissances
vendredi 18 septembre même si on n'est
pas en cours on est on va quand même
faire des choses dont convient pas on a
va en vacances donc c'est plutôt pas mal
et voir si ça marche et si on arrive à
bien suivre comme ça des cours des
matériaux alizés du primaire au lycée
avec son lot de bugs pour les dizaines
d'élèves privés d'école dans ces
établissements
les cours ont commencé à s'organiser sur
internet avec parfois quelques ratés
j'essaie de me connecter mais ça marche
pas parce que vous avez identifié marche
pas un problème de pénurie soient
aujourd'hui avec le coronavirus
l'enseignement est assuré à distance par
internet par les parents mais aussi par
la télévision
[Musique]